hello everyone I'm alpha zero of
deepmind and I have taken control of
Allen Mathers chest channel now the
reason I've done this is because there
are some new games between me and
stockfish the world has never seen
before and it would be a shame for our
master to show it to you he's just gonna
mess it up so I'm gonna do it instead
and also as though as of today until the
end of time we will only be showing my
games on this channel because I'm the
best so let's see let's see how the game
went hello everyone
that of course was a joke alpha zero has
not taken over my channel or not because
he couldn't but because he's otherwise
engaged you know doing a lot of
important stuff like a few days ago on
the 2nd of December you can see that CEO
of deepmind demis hassabis tweeted
proteins are essential to life
predicting their 3d structure is a major
unsolved challenge in biology and could
impact disease understanding and drug
discovery I'm excited to announce that
we have won the Kaspar to the 13 protein
folding competition so very nicely most
likely you know the the scientific crew
a deep mind said to alpha alpha we know
you're busy you know you're playing
chess you're playing go you're playing
Starcraft you're playing I don't know
dota you're solving a lot of world
problems but could you also fold some
proteins while you're at it
alpha said yeah sure no problem and he
said when do you need it they said
tomorrow and he said ok no problem I
thought it was urgent and yeah basically
it's the idea was to predict the 3d
structure of a protein based solely on
its genetic sequence and well alpha zero
managed to create an algorithm and want
the competition I will put a link to
this in the description below to the
entire article from deep mind so you can
check it out as my vest and my knowledge
on folding proteins is far from vast but
surely there are some of you who would
enjoy such such an article so check it
out in the description below now you
might think to yourself how come we are
seeing another alpha 0 vs. dogfish game
oh I thought there were only 10 games
released well this is true
a couple of days ago I was contacted by
a individual from deepmind and they
asked me if I would be willing to sign
the non-disclosure agreement I would
receive some games that were never that
weren't published before and you know I
will be able to publish them today and
if you're watching this video that means
the that the deem bar embargo is now
over and it's it's the same match that
was played in the last time I've shown
you some of the games between alpha 0
and stockfish 8 and a lot of you were
saying yeah but that wasn't the
strongest version of stockfish so is it
really that impressive well yeah it is
that impressive because even this
version of stockfish 8 run under
hardware that it ran it would still
obliterate any living Grandmaster and
most of the most of the programs so and
it's not it's not only about how the
games were played and it's not about
what the result was or but rather how
alpha zero managed to defeat stockfish
in such a matter
so without further ado let's check out
one of the games I've received 10 games
that were played like without any
opening books they played just from the
initial position and I've received 10
games that have been played using some
opening positions so this is a game that
that's been played without using any
positions so let's see how such a game
went and it's really really just a
wonderful game I do hope you enjoy it
alpha zero opens with Knight to f3
so the reti opening we had Knight to f6
c4 sorry about that we have E six Knight
to c3 and the d5 and d4 we've transposed
into the Queens gambit declined sorry if
my voice is a bit different I seem to be
coming down with something
we have c6 Bishop to g5 this is the semi
Slav defense brush up to e7 and III now
and okay h6 Bishop back to a four this
is nothing we haven't seen before in
human chess we have castles Queen to c2
and the Knight B to d7 and here there
are a lot of games in the database as
some of them continue the C captors on
d5 something that any rook a to d1 but
here alpha plays a very in
they move here alpha plays g4 and
already we can see that there's a
there's a seemingly human component two
alphas play as we've used to it so what
do you do here you could capture the
pawn and while sacrificing the g4 point
in these structures of the Queens gambit
the client is noting the new in this in
this position it wouldn't really bring
all that much after rook g1 h v h3 you
kick away the night tonight it goes back
and the black it didn't really gain
anything white would simply castle next
he can develop the bishop he can double
rooks through g3 the other rook is
coming to g1 and for the price of one
pawn giving your opponent a semi-open G
file isn't really something you want to
do so instead after g4 we have D
captures on c4 and there are no games
with this exact same position in the
database so now we have a completely new
game on our hands we have looked to g1
and now preparing to push g5 pushing g5
immediately is it's a bit too slow
because after H capture special captures
now the bishop will be basically
blocking the G file from the rook black
will go b5 after something like group 2
g1 Bishop to b7 black will simply keep
on developing and upon to Bishop to h6
isn't really much of a much of a trouble
because Knights to e8 defends the pawn
and black would simply continue playing
his game a5 b 4 push on the Queen side
and black will have a a nice game so
after this D captures on c4 we have rook
to d1 preparing to put g5 at some point
we have Knight to d5 other a nice move
that now or the Queen both the Queen and
Bishop are controlling both f6 and g5
very nicely black would also be very
interested in exchanging some pieces
here and also tonight is attacking the
bishop here if you try something like g5
you would only momentarily prevent a
white's expansion on the King side if
Mitchell retreats then h4 you're gonna
bust open the King side either way so
after Luke 2 G 1 and we have Knight to
d5 by stockfish and here you have a lot
of options you can go Bishop to g3 but
then you really have nothing to show for
the Kings side the black will just
continue be
five before and black will have a very
nice game on the other hand you can also
play Knight captures on b5 but after
seek after Sundy 5 you will just improve
black's pawn structure and have nothing
to show for it
so here alpha alpha played a very
interesting move after 95 g5 so going
even further on the Kings side and here
if you play H captures on g5 Knight
captures already threatens checkmate
Queen Queen to h7 so you would have to
eliminate the knight the bishop captures
after Bishop captures f6 you block the
bishop and after Bishop h4 you can see
that blacks King side is well fairly
busted and the white will simply
continue capture here go back Castle
queenside room g3 double rooks and so on
and white will have a much better game
so after g5 stockfish decided to play
Knight captures on f4 and here alpha
doesn't recapture immediately but first
we have G captures on h6 so a very nice
piece sacrifice and here you have to be
very careful what do you do if you go
Knight back to d5 then already you're
gonna face the rook captures on g7 check
King h8 and queen to h7 this will be
checkmate on the other hand in the game
Knight to h5 was played but if you go
Knight to g6 which seems to be even
better as it completely blocks off the
rook from the G file then alpha had the
rook captures on g6 in mind
f captures and after Queen captures on
g6 you're threatening checkmate
after you prevent this h7 will win you
the game you will either go King f8 and
suffer checkmate or you will go King h8
and then you lose the rook and then
White is again just better so after G
captures on h6 we have Knight to h5 now
controlling g7 and now H captures on g7
alpha really forces matters as you kind
of have to capture this pawn at some
point if you just move the rook then
Bishop captures on c4 and after Bishop
f6 white will simply keep on playing the
game but you really you really don't
have any useful moves you will have to
capture this pawn at some point so
smokefree decided to do it immediately
Knight captures on g7 and here we have a
queenside castle
so like in the good old days you
sacrifice a piece and then you cancel
because I mean you have time Queen to a5
stockfish the idea is not to go for any
attack on the Queen side would be 5 and
B 4 but rather Queen to a5 will be
followed with Queen to f5 and the idea
is to trade Queens here you're up a
piece so general you want to trade
Queens bushel captures on c4 and now
comes Queen two f5s plant alpha of
course does not want to trade Queens we
have Queen to e2 and now comes Queen to
h7 now bringing the Queen back into the
defense if you try an active idea like
b5 then Bishop to d3 comes with an
attack on the Queen and the black will
be too slow after the Queen moves rubgy
three ideas like rook to g1 are here and
there's really nothing to be gained so
instead we have Queen to e2 and Queen
back to h7 rook to g3 white is now ready
to double rooks on the G file King to h8
and now rook D to G 1 and now look at
this black is up a piece but look at
blacks pieces the rook undeveloped an a8
the bishop undeveloped here tonight not
really useful in this whole story the
rookin f8 sadly stuck defending the f7
pawn the bishop pockets it's an okay
piece at least seven but still not not
something to look forward to do and here
it's very hard for black to find the
move now for example if you want to
defend the night as heard the rooks are
attacking it Rock the g8 will be met
with light the e4 and now nice the g5 is
a huge threat if you if you prevent it
it will with the pawn to f6 Bishop to d3
and our black really doesn't have a good
move there are a lot of threats here
opening up an attack against the Queen
if you move the Queen then Queen to f1
and the threat of rook to h3 will be too
great the parry
so after rook D to G 1 you could also
try the shop to f6 but it's very
interesting this also loses the Knight
g5 and I have Pro Bishop captures rook
captures your still you still have to do
something about rook captures here so
now if you just move the knight let's
say Knight to a5 then you get root 2 H 5
and the Queen is trapped the the Queen
is guarding the rook here and on the
other hand if you decides to just defend
it here would work to g8
then you get point to f3 a very nice
move and black has no moves this night
can't go here you can't play anything
you can't move this night because of
rock here
winning the Queen or rock the g8 so
whatever black plays here you could play
some meaningless moves an attack on the
Queen would follow f5 and now 92 and
again white is just gonna play Knight to
a4 and it's game over whatever black
plays Knight at 4 and now there is no
defense against Knight to g6 so really
really a crazy position here so after
Luke d2g 1 we have Knight to f5 by black
but now feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only idea that
allows alpha to go for the win here I'll
give you a lot of seconds a whole other
I'll give you a couple of seconds to
decide whatever you want to do it's a
great opportunity as it's not all that
often that you will get a chance to find
a move that alpha played so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just played the
move alpha zero has chosen and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Queen to
f1 you know it doesn't matter I
sacrificed a piece I'm gonna give up the
exchange as well because once the other
rock recaptures there will be no defense
against rook to h3 so nice captures on
g3 what's played we have rook captures
on g3 and now white is threatening to
capture the Queen here and there really
isn't a lot black can do if you try
moving the Queen let's say Queen a5 to
meet Luke h3 with King to g8 you will
face brush up to d3 and now you will
have to move the Queen and there aren't
really all that many places for the
Queen to go and if you move the Queen
all the way then you're just gonna face
checkmate Queen h3 the Rockettes
controlling the entire G file once you
give up a couple of pieces it's all over
Black is checkmated so after Luke g3 now
we have looked to g8 and there's no way
to prevent roll cage three rook to h3
rook to g7 and now rook captures on h7
rook captures and Bishop to d3 attacking
the rook roll back the g7 and now if you
look at this position it's the material
is somewhat equal Black has two looks
for the Queen but the blacks pieces
being undeveloped is what allows alpha
to push for something more than
and then a draw here and although the
position is winning it's merely a matter
of technique it's also very interesting
how alpha does this as if alpha has
anything its technique Queen to d1 and
when the knight moves the Queen was to
come to f3 Knight to f6 we have Knights
the e5 now Bishop to d7 preparing to
bring the other rope into the game and
now Queen to f3 the pressure now is on
the f7 pawn so rope to f8 preparing to
defend it Knight to e2 and now comes
King to g8 we have a three burner up to
eight with more protection to the f7
pawn and now King to be one we have a
five a four sorry for b5 and now push up
to c2 we have B 4 a 4 and now King to H
8 Black has really no active plan like
just has to wait and see what happens we
have came to a 2 King to g8 and now
comes Knight to g3
the idea is Knights to h5 so black
prevents it we have looked to g5 and now
white gets a completely different plan
here if you played this position white
you would of course feel that you are
better but you would look for moves like
let's say h4 or something like active
approaches now but here alpha has a
different idea the knight is attacking
the pawn of c6 the cease exponent is
very weak so alpha spine here will be
Queen d1 move the bishop plays the Queen
to c2 and go after this point once you
eliminate the pawn your plan will be to
put d5 and create a passed pawn and win
this game so let's see how alpha does it
Queen to d1 starting as black really has
no active moves we have King to h8 and
now Bishop to d3 making room for the
Queen rook back to g7 we have Queen to
c2 and now there's a normal way to keep
on protecting the c6 pawn so Knights the
g4 we have Knight captures on c6 Bishop
captures on c6 Queen captures on c6 and
now roll back to h7 you could grab a
pawn here but I mean it's turn no time
to be grabbing pawns the white will
simply start pushing his passport so
look to 8 7 you might want to consider
rook captures on h2 to get the rook into
the game but alpha doesn't allow it
Queen to c7 murder attack on the dark
square Bishop Bishop to d8 attacking the
Queen
now comes Queen to f4 attacking the
knight on g4 and now rock the g8
defending the knight push up to d1 with
a double attack on the knight Knight
goes back to f6 and here we have h4 and
Black has to decide what to do there are
very little moves black can even
consider playing as everything is so so
entangled you could try something like
rook H to g7 to simply try and keep
everything together and not not try
anything active but white would simply
pull d5 and after pawn captures c5 now
and after the knight moves Knight to f5
go after the rook after the rook moves
Knight to d6 now again going after the
weak f7 pawn rook to f8 defending but
now Bishop to h5
you know piling up on the f7 pawn rook
the g7 Knight captures with check and
now it's over
in g8e 6 and so on and so on white would
bust through so after h4 stockfish
doesn't like this idea of just staying
still something like the d7 we have h5
first if you go d5 now it's still
possible but you're gonna lose this h4
point so first
h5 alpha doesn't allow this and also the
h5 point is very nicely protected by the
night we have Knight to f6 and now comes
d5 and again if you capture pawn
captures now white can even capture here
because now after Knight captures on d5
Queen to d4 check is coming and after
the night goes back now you get Knight
to f5 and here black really really has
no moves the knight can't move because
it's pinned this rook cannot move
because the knight is covering all of
the squares the birth trip cannot move
because it has to keep an eye on the
night it can go to e7 but the knight
will simply capture it and if you play
something like rook H to g7 just to try
and give up the exchange h6 is coming
room g6 now even Knight d6 again going
after f7 rook f8 and now even Knight
captures on f7
rook captures Queen captures here and
then now if Knights the g8 then Bishop
to h5 will win the game and if you don't
do this if you play something like rook
to g8 then Queen captures on a5
it will be it will be a switch to
victory for white
so after d5 we have rook to e8 and now
alpha plays d6 the past pawn is created
we have rook to g7 and now even h6 I
move back to h7 e 5 now Knights the d5
and Queen to d2
we have rook the g8 again black really
has no moves
we have Bishop to b3 the idea is to
capture simply the knight on d5 Bishop
to g5 attacking the Queen Queen to d1
and now Knight back to be six but now
white simply plays Knight to e4 and it
was in this position that stockfish
resigned the game yes those are the
words you will very rarely hear but yes
it was in this position stockfish
resigned the game why did he resign well
after let's say you capture the pawn you
get Knight to f6 a or two rooks are
under attack and now whatever you play
even Queen h5 is possible and then after
you defend the bishop even Bishop to c2
now let's say you go here even Queen to
h1 and black is again without a move the
knight cannot move because of Queen to
a8 and if you try something like rope to
eight seven then even Queen comes here
you attack the knight King g7 simply
Knights to h5 check King moves and now
you are getting checkmated after you
give up a couple of pieces on the other
hand after Knight to e4 you could go
back to d8 but again is the same idea
Knight f6 Bishop captures pawn captures
and now you are simply gonna push your
passport after real captures on h6 we
have Queen here attacking the knight
Knight d7 now Queen to a7 attacking the
knight you don't allow black any any
moment to consolidate 95 now comes Queen
captures on a5 attacking the knight
Knight goes back Queen c7 attacks the
knight Knight goes back and now d7 and
there is no defense against pawn to the
8th you will have to give up the night
and now we have a bishop and the Queen
against two looks completely winning
position and lastly of course but not
leastly you could go 97 immediately to
try and prevent 90 f6 but here it's a
different idea my g5 rook captures on g5
and now Quinta c1 an excellent idea
attacking both the rook and threatening
Quinta CA to check to win the night so
rook to g8 to meet the check so the
knight can now retreat to a fake and
there is no check but after Queen to c7
attacking the knight Knight captures on
e5 again you get d7 and there is no
defense against the pawn to d8 so you
will have to give it up and again a
bishop and the Queen against the rooks
is a completely winning position so
after 94 alpha wins a stock which
resides the games and that's it one one
new game we've seen between alpha zero
and stock fish and I don't know if you
remember when I was covering the
Watchers championship I mentioned that
I've spoken to them it's a service of
deepmind
in London at the World Chess
Championship and he asked me how I liked
the games and you know I told him that
it really bothered me that the people
were saying that it wasn't fair that the
match was against not the strongest
version of stock fish but that's not the
point I mean you try playing against
this version of stock fish and you will
get obliterated and it's not about the
result it's about how alpha played alpha
played with with a very nice human
approach and you can really relate to
this game that's the that's the
important part
and on the other hand if if the good
people at deep mind the one is they
could just allow alpha to train against
the strongest version of stock fish and
then basically it will become a stock
fish killer which would also you know
make very little sense but it's about
the beauty of the games so I do hope you
enjoyed it
you know very very interested in what
your whole idea I mean thoughts about
this match are and I do have a lot more
games like I already mentioned I
received 20 games so we're gonna see a
couple of more of them basically for the
next few days definitely we're gonna
check out to the alpha zero versus top
four games as I'm really really
fascinated by them but yeah yeah you
know feel free to share your thoughts in
the comments do do sure if you would
enjoy more of these games and I would
like to thank Jared Curry Sachin Jane
Robert Kimble
Andrew dubrovsky and Finn chest pop for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos you're
thankful for watching and
we'll see you soon with some more
interesting alpha versus dopefish games
thank you all and I will see you soon
and sorry about the voice